[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unboxed exciting
stuff today it's been a little over 2
years now since Nvidia released the
mighty GeForce RTX 4090 an insane $1600
us GPU that smashed the previous
generation Flagship part by a 60% margin
as in this thing was 60% faster on
average at 4K so while grossly expensive
it was still tremendously EX exciting
for highend gaming so that being the
case it is super exciting today that I
can finally show you the new GeForce RTX
4090 TI 59 uh 90 sorry uh yeah sorry I
mean the GeForce RTX 5090 yes
so after two years a little over two
years we can now show you nvidia's next
Generation GPU code named Blackwell and
the new flagship once again costs a
cool2 $ us so what's an offer here and
how are Nvidia able to charge $2,000 us
for the new RTX 49ti sa it's a
90 silly me I do mean RTX
90 well nvidia's been put in a bit of a
difficult position here because while
the new 50 Series takes advantage of
Cutting Edge technology such as PCI
Express 5.0 and gddr 7 memory Nvidia has
been forced to use the same same tsmc 4N
process as the previous generation so no
node improvements and that being the
case there's not too much they can
really do short of a architectural
overhaul which I don't suppose they were
ready to do just yet today's sponsor
spot is brought to you by Asus and their
entire range of AMD x870 motherboards
featuring robust vrm configurations
designed to tackle amd's latest ryen
9000 series of processes with e whether
it be the affordable Prime x870 DP Wi-Fi
or class leading Rog Crosshair x870 hero
the hero also takes advantage of asus's
Cutting Edge Nitro path Dam technology
which provides the best ddr5 memory
performance of any x870 motherboard
we've tested and we've tested just about
all of them there's also a number of
features on offer that make the DIY
processor Breeze such as m.2 Q release
m.2 Q slide m.2 Q latch PCI slot Q
release slim Q antenna and Q LED there's
loads more features so many in fact that
I couldn't cover them even if this was a
10-minute ad read so for more
information please check the links in
the video description therefore the only
way to make a faster GPU is to make a
bigger one so bigger it is the D is now
23% larger packing 33% more cores and
with 32 GB of 28 GBS per second gddr 7
memory on a 512 bit wide memory bus you
get a bandwidth of
1,792 GB per second which is a hefty 78%
increase over the RTX 490 so that means
the RTX 9
5090 uh yeah it's a big unit and
therefore comes with an even bigger
price tag making this thing 25% more
expensive than the RTX
490 so that being the case it would want
to be a lot faster certainly faster than
the specs suggest so let's go find out
out actually before we jump into the
blue bar graphs here's a look at how
nvidia's found is Edition version of the
RTX 590 handles and I'll compare it to
the RTX 490 Fe card so for this testing
we're using The Last of Us Part One at
4K with the maxed out quality settings
and after an hour of load inside an
enclosed ATX case in a 21° room we saw a
peak GPU temperature of 73° which is
remarkable given how quiet and compact
this graphics card is the fan speed
peaked at just, 1600 RPM and couldn't be
heard over our case fans which are
already very quiet the cor is clocked at
an average frequency of
2,655 MHz with an average GPU power of
492 wats the memory temp peaked at 88°
with an operating frequency of
2,334 MHz for a transfer speed of 28
gbits per second now compare that to the
4090 Fe model which peaked at 68° for
the C and A Memory temperature 80° while
the fans spun at just shy of 1500 RPM so
it's clear that the 590 is a little bit
louder and a little bit hotter but given
that the 590 was also consuming on
average 35% more power in this test and
is a considerably smaller graphics card
the results are pretty
incredible so I'm extremely impressed
with what Nvidia has been able to
achieve here this might be the most
impressive graphics card we've ever seen
and you'd never guess just by looking at
how much thermal load this cooler can
efficiently handle great stuff indeed
but of course now you want to know how
does it
perform starting with Marvel Rivals at
1440p we see that the 90 is delivering
30% more performance than the 4090 which
is a decent performance improvement
though once you're factor in the 25%
price hike it's considerably less
exciting jumping up to the 4K resolution
only slightly increases the margin to
33% which again is a solid uplift it's
just a shame that it comes at such an
extreme price premium stalker 2 isn't
the most well optimized game I guess you
could say and as a result maxed out the
RTX 590 is only good for 94 FPS at 1440p
making it 22% faster than the 4090 so a
very mild performance gain there
thankfully at 4K we are looking at a
much more reasonable 42% performance
gain rendering 71 FPS on average next up
we have Counter Strike 2 and the 1440p
results look a bit odd as the RTX 90 is
slightly slower than the 490 here though
the 1% lows were notably stronger now it
is worth noting that we saw multiple
examples where the 90 was actually
slower than the 4090 at 1080p suggesting
that there is a possible overhead issue
here with the Blackwell architecture but
it could also be just an issue where
5090 has so many cores that it can't be
efficiently utilized at such a low
resolution so we'll have to investigate
this one further
but even at 4K the 90 isn't much faster
than the 4090 just an 8% increase here
and the issue doesn't appeared to be a
CPU bottleneck given how much higher the
frame rates were at
1440p performance in God of War Ragnarok
is insane at 1440p 268 FPS using the
ultra preset that said this did only
make it 22% faster than the 4090 at
1440p so pretty poor given it cost 25%
more
the 590 does scale better at 4K though
opening up to a 36% margin with 195 FPS
opposed to 143 FPS with the RTX 490 so
pretty good win here next up we have
Delta Force and at 1440p the 590 is
providing just 177% more performance
than the 490 though to be fair frame
rates are extreme and likely approaching
a CPU bottleneck still while jumping up
to 4K does extend the margin out to 27%
% that's still not a terribly impressive
uplift despite rendering 160 FPS and
again this is largely due to the fact
that the 590 cost 25% more and is
arriving a little over 2 years later as
we know Space Marine 2 is a very CP
limited game and at 1440p we certainly
appear to be fighting the limits of the
ryzen 7 9800 x3d however what's really
odd here is the fact that the 590 is
coming in 4% slower than the 490 so as
we've seen a few times now though mostly
at 1080p this either suggests to me that
there's some kind of overhead issue or
the workload is limited in a way that
makes the 5090 inefficient due to how
many cores it has thankfully though
switching up to the 4K resolution does
solve this problem and now the 90 is
seen to be 30% faster than the 490 which
as I've noted number of times now it's
an okay performance uplift it's
certainly not amazing it's decent though
but it's also entirely undone by the
fact that it also costs 25% more the
Star Wars jedo Survivor performance
Improvement at 1440p is again weak just
a 14% Improvement here though we are
looking at 191 FPS on average which is
very impressive then at 4K we're
creeping over the 100 FPS barrier with
102 FPS making the RTX 590 21% faster
than the 490 so again a pretty
disappointing margin there moving on to
a plag toil requium we see that at 1440p
the 590 is just 21% faster than the
490 though the data is in part CPU
limited as indicated by these similar 1%
lows jumping up to 4K does help with
that here the RTX 590 is able to pull
much further ahead of the 490 and is now
delivering a 42% performance uplift so
certainly one of the better margins
we've
seen cyberpunk 2077 is another game
where the 90 struggles to offer
noteworthy gains over the 4090 at
1440p just a 19% Improvement here again
with similar 1% lows though of course
other system limitations will be coming
into effect here an increase in the
resolution opens the margin up to
32% which I'd still say is quite
underwhelming despite performance
overall being excellent though we are
using the second highest pret and rate
tracing hasn't been enabled frame rates
and Dying Light to using the high preset
are extreme at 1440p 198 FPS for the new
RTX 590 though that did only make it 24%
faster than the 4090 and then even at 4K
we're still looking at a 25% performance
gain over the 4090 which scales with the
25% price increase so probably not
amazing there in terms of value Dragon
Age the valard is limited to just shy of
130 FPS at 1440p when using the ultra
preset which does selectively apply some
rad Trac effects so be aware that this
portion of the review isn't looking
exclusively at rasterization performance
though that is still mostly the focus
here then we see that even when
increasing the resolution to 4K the 90
is still just 10% faster than the 490
with 96 FPS on average so a very
disappointing result there War Thunder
obviously plays at extreme frame rates
even with the highest quality preset
enabled and at 1440p where clearly CPU
limit
and I can confirm this as we saw the
same results at 10p moving to 4K though
does remove the CPU limits but even so
the 590 is just 15% faster than the 490
granted though we are at well over 300
FPS which is probably more than enough
to play this game but when talking about
relative performance the 90 is very
disappointing in this
example Marvel's Spider-Man remastered
is yet another game that is heavily CPU
Limited at 1440p with these extreme high
in gpus and that means both the 4090 and
5090 were limited to 222 FPS so very
good performance overall but that
limitation there meant that the 90 was
no faster than the 490 and then
increasing to 4K it does mostly remove
those limits though I suspect the 90 is
probably still being held back a little
bit by the CPU as it averaged 212 FPS
and as a result the 90 was just 26%
faster than the
490 Hogwarts Legacy is yet another new
game that is mostly CPU Limited at 1440
p as a result the 490 and 90 delivered
similar performance then pushing the
resolution up to 4K allowed the 5090 to
pull ahead of the 4090 by a 31% margin
so pretty amazing performance overall
but not exactly amazing in terms of
value The Last of Us Part One does allow
the 5090 to provide a decent performance
uplift at 1440p here it's 28% faster
with 204 FPS on average so pretty
amazing performance overall then at 4K
we're looking at a 40% increase with 125
FPS on average so a great result here at
least relative to most other games now
the RTX 590 is able to render over 100
FPS in Star Wars Outlaws at 1440p using
the ultra preset and this game does
force the use of rracing and this meant
it was 22% faster than the 490 at
1440p though quite oddly the margin is
reduced at 4K and now the 90 is just 19%
faster so a similar margin overall but
typically we'd expect the 90 to look
better at 4K but that's certainly not
the case here finally we have Starfield
and here the 90 is just 4% fast than the
1490 at 1440p using the ultra quality
settings and this limited performance to
125 FPS moving to 4K didn't really help
too much as here the 90 was just 7%
faster than the 4090 so there's some
kind of limitation in this title that is
stopping the 90 from delivering the
margins that we've typically seen in
other titles at 4K now although we
didn't look at the 10p data for the
individual games because probably a bit
pointless for this particular product
given that it's almost always going to
be heavily CPU limited I will give you a
look at the average results across the
17 games tested because well I have the
data so we might as well quickly look at
it and as you can see the 490 and 590
data is heavily CPU limited which is why
these high-end Flagship gpus at a low
resolution make for a perfect CPU
Benchmark and this data also highlights
why you want to have a highend CPU to
utilize a highend GPU like the
5090 even at 1440p the 590 was often
heavily CPU limited and as a result was
just 12% faster than the 490 across
these 17 games tested then at 4K the
5090 was on average 27% faster which is
a truly disapp Po in margin given that
it costs 25% more this is why I've joked
multiple times about the 590 actually
being a 490 TI because really that's
exactly what it is or at least that's
what it looks like even if the 90
maintained the same $1600 us MSRP as the
4090 it would be pretty underwhelming
for a Next Generation Flagship GPU the
4090 for example was on average 60%
faster than the 390 TI while also coming
in at a lower price or it was 73% faster
than the 390 from me 7% price hike so
you can see why the 5090 is so extremely
underwhelming now for a look at power
consumption and please forgive me but
for the bulk of our power data it was
recorded at 1440p which isn't ideal for
measuring the true power usage of the
RTX 590 but I'll run a few separate
tests anyway in Starfield at 1440p power
consumption increased by 12% with the
590 over the 490 then in Star Wars
Outlaws we saw a 177% increase in power
usage at 1440p going from 532 wats up to
624 wats I also recorded power usage in
Space Marine 2 not expecting the 590 to
actually be slower than the 490 at 1440p
and as a result it consumed 15% less
power but at least it shows when not
under full load the 590 is very
efficient but what I have done is go
back and retest the 7900 xdx 4090 and 90
at 4K in three games where the 90
performed well at 4K and those games
Were Dying Light to cyberpunk 2077 and a
plague tail requium here we see that the
90 increased power usage by 37 to 41%
depending on the title which is more in
line with the performance gains seen in
those titles and I am combining both CPU
and GPU power usage for these numbers as
we have seen in the past that GeForce
gpus can increase CPU load which helps
reduce GPU load and therefore power
consumption finally I also reran those
same tests but with a 60 FPS cap and
there's some interesting results here
testing with a play Tower requ and power
usage of the 4090 and 90 was extremely
similar when CT at 60 FPS the 590 only
increased consumption by 2% but we did
see an 8% increase in cyber Punk and
then a 15% increase in Dying Light
too okay so unfortunately I have had
some issues with Metro Exodus enhanced
Edition when using the rad on gpus I've
been able to run this game in the past
on RAD on gpus but for whatever reason
it is now broken with the radon gpus
when enabling raid tracing hard locking
the system every time I try and load
into a game and I've tried multiple AMD
and Intel systems with no joy AMD has
been made aware of this issue and have
successfully replicated the problem but
sadly a fix was not issued in time for
this review so rather than drop the game
entirely I've decided to go with without
any Ray tracing data for the radon gpus
as we're just really looking at the 490
versus 590 performance anyway also Metro
Exodus enhanced was one of the few rate
tracing titles that Tim believed to be
truly transformative with rate tracing
enabled so I did really want to include
it now at 1080p the 590 was 21% faster
than the 490 and then 33% faster at
1440p and please note I didn't test 4K
rate tracing performance because most
title see very poor and almost always
unplayable performance at 4K even with
upscaling but granted in this example
the 5090 and even the 4090 would work
well at
4K an example where that's less true is
Allen wake 2 and for this testing
quality upscaling has been enabled at
1080p the 90 is just 19% faster than the
4090 and moving to 1440p doesn't really
help here we're looking at an 18% margin
so overall pretty weak gains for the 90
in Allen wake 2 with rad tracing enabled
and we're only just breaking the 100 FPS
barrier moving on to cyberpunk 2077
Phantom Liberty using the ultra quality
rate tracing preset with quality
upscaling we see the 4090 and 90 are
comparable at 1080p almost certainly due
to CPU
limitations then increasing the
resolution to 40 and 40p helps the 5090
a little bit but even so it's just 11%
faster than the 4090 rendering 129 FPS
Marvel Spider-Man remastered sees
performance heavily CPU Limited at both
1080P and 1440p which is problematic as
we're only talking about 128 FPS at
1440p and this was achieved by the 4080
super now you could argue that we need
to include 4K benchmarks here but I'm
more concerned with the fact that 128
FPS is the cap granted that's still very
good performance overall but for those
with high refresh rate monitors it's
more of a starting point and I can't
imagine too many people spending $2,000
us or more on a graphics card will be
happy gaming at say around 60 FPS which
is likely where you'd find yourself at
4K especially without the aid of
upscaling now the Dying Light 2 results
are interesting as here we're using the
high Ray tracing preset with quality
upscaling and at 1080p the RTX 5090
rendered 208 FPS on average making it
18% faster than the
490 and interestingly we're not CPU
Limited at 1440p but even so the 90 is
just 22% faster than the 4090 so an
extremely disappointing result finally
we have black myth Wukong and previously
using the very high rate tracing preset
with the 4090 it was only good for 92
FPS at 108p with quality upscaling the
90 is able to deliver an additional 34%
performance averaging 123
FPS and then the 440p data it's quite
similar at least to the margins as here
the 59 to 30 6% faster rendering 98 FPS
so not amazing performance overall
especially given we've had to enable
upscaling but relative to past products
it's a reasonable step
forward Okay so we've had to go with a
five game average for the r tracing data
as I couldn't include Metro Exodus
enhanced given the radon gpus didn't
work so on average we saw a 14%
performance Improvement for the 590 over
the 1490 at 1080p with upscaling then at
1440p we saw an average just a 17%
performance increase and it's
interesting to note that at 1440p with
upscaling we're looking at just 123 FPS
on average which really isn't a lot
considering we're using a $2,000 us
graphics card okay so here's how the
current and previous generation
mid-range to highend gpus compare in
terms of value based on the MSRP at
$2,000 us the RTX 590 is 1 1 12% better
value per frame than the
4090 so in other words after a little
over 2 years we're seeing no improvement
in cost per frame the 5090 is
essentially just a faster GeForce 40
series
GPU but if we shift to the best retail
pricing for Mid 2024 and just assume
that the RTX 590 will actually sell for
$2,000 us it does look a little bit
better but I guess do we honestly
believe the 590 will be $2,000 us do we
really believe that yeah it's probably
going to be pretty damn ugly in terms of
value because at $2,000 us it's it's
already pretty ugly so there you have it
the RTX 490 to it's a 90 I mean RTX
590 uh yeah it's now the world's fastest
gaming GPU so no shocker there what is
shocking though at least based on our
testing is that was on average just 27%
faster than the 490 at 4K while it costs
at least 25% more which is why I have
repeatedly referred to this as the RTX
409 TI but thank you Bal for all the
corrections you're welcome but let's be
real here that is exactly what this
thing is nvidia's tried to disguise the
fact that you know it's not just a
beefed up 4090 by dangling stuff like
dss4 multiframe generation in the face
of Gamers as if they're Toddlers and
dlss 4 is a shiny set of keys and on
that note I've not mentioned frame
generation until now which might seem a
bit odd given how heavily nvidia's
pushed the ss4 as a key feature of this
product and really the feature of the
entire GeForce 50 Series but we do have
a few issues with this and look firstly
I'll just note that we do have an
in-depth and dedicated dss4 analysis
coming in the next few days it'll be a
separate content piece that'll be put
together by Tim the reason we tackle
stuff like frame generation and
upscaling and their own dedicated
content pieces because they are very
involved to test correctly the testing
is far less about the frame rate stuff
that you see in all the graphs and that
and it's more about image quality and in
the case of frame gen it's also
important to look at latency in short
I'm just going to say it frame
generation doesn't deliver what nvidia's
marketing claims it does it's not a true
performance- enhancing feature you're
not really going from 60 fps to 120 FPS
or whatever number they happen to be
claiming you're getting the apparent
smoothness of those higher frame rates
with possible graphical artifacts but
what you're not getting is the true
benefits of higher frame rates and that
is improved latency now just to be clear
I'm not saying frame generation isn't
useful good technology or that you
shouldn't use it but I am saying Nvidia
has weaponized this feature to mislead
you guys the consumers claiming nonsense
like the upcoming RTX 5070 is faster
than an RTX 40 90 that is fundamentally
not true I also strongly believe that
showing frame generation performance in
a benchmark graph is misleading and
while Nvidia would love us to do just
that uh we view it as an extremely
slippery slope for gamers it's a race to
the bottom winning benchmarks will
quickly become about who can spit out
the most amount of interpolated frames
uh input and visual quality be damned in
short as it stands in its current
iterations so dss3 and DSs for frame
generation it's nothing more than a
frame smoothing technology which can
under the right conditions be useful and
an effective technology but it doesn't
boost FPS performance it merely Smooths
the presentation moreover it is
completely useless for any kind of
competitive shooter or fast-paced game
where the entire point of seeking higher
FPS is to improve latency so while
Nvidia might like to think or pretend
that all Gamers will and should use
frame generation in reality that could
not be further from the truth now moving
on to another topic CPU performance it's
very clear based on the 1440p data that
if you're buying an RTX 5090 you want to
make sure you have a 9800x 3D because
even with the zen5 3D vcash processor
you're still going to end up CPU limited
more often than not especially if you're
aiming for high refresh rate performance
with stuff like rad tracing
enabled speaking of Raad tracing you're
almost certainly going to see reviews
where the RT performance of the RTX 5090
relative to the 4090 is more impressive
than what we saw for the majority of our
testing and this will come down to the
quality settings used the goal of our
testing here was to prioritize what we
felt to be more real world settings
settings that allow for frame rates
North of 60 FPS as I don't think many
gamers spending $2,000 us on a graphics
card will be content with conso like
frame rates but in an effort to provide
a bit more context here I've gone back
and got some scaling data with black
myth Wukong for our review I tested at
144p using dlss quality upscaling and
this allowed the RTX 590 to deliver 98
FPS not exactly extreme High refresh
rate stuff but good performance overall
and this s it beat the 4090 by a 24%
margin but if we turn off upscaling
which we feel most Gamers won't do when
using rate tracing they'll almost
certainly use upscaling but if we turn
it off the frame rate of the 90 drops to
64 FPS but this also meant that it was
now 45% faster than the 4090 so a far
more impressive margin there and this is
comparable to what we saw at 4K using
dlss upscaling though again we're only
gaming at around 60 FPS which some
Gamers will find acceptable but I
personally find it less than desirable
especially when spending so much money
but the point is the 5090 really can be
40 to 50% faster than the 4090 it just
depends on the game and the quality
settings used but as we've seen in this
review typically speaking if you're
targeting big frame rates the difference
between the 5090 and 4090 can be much
smaller so all said and done I think
it's fair to say overall the GeForce RTX
90 is a disappointing product despite
being a very impressive performer it's
disappointing because it doesn't do what
a Next Generation product should do at
least in our opinion it fails to move
the needle forward in terms of value and
it could just as easily slot into the
GeForce 40 series again if it was
released as an RTX 4090 ti no one would
think twice now I've acknowledged that
Nvidia couldn't do too much here given
the process node limitations but they
still could have created a more exciting
product series had the 590 cost $1600 us
it'd be a lot more impressive still not
amazing not nearly as good as say the
3090 to 490 upgrade in fact it would be
half as good but it would also be worlds
better than It ultimately is that said I
expect the RTX 590 will probably age
quite well the 27% margin we see here on
average when compared to the 4090 will
almost certainly increase over time how
much is hard to say but I think we will
see many more examples of up around 40%
than what we did here today this also
means that the more affordable models
are likely to be pretty underwhelming
I'm sad to say only offering very minor
performance gains over the parts they're
replacing now again inidia could have
improved things here by offering
satisfactory vram configurations 12 GB
on the RTX 5070 for example it's a joke
the card should be armed with a minimum
of 16 GB and had they done that it might
have ended up being a worthwhile upgrade
from the RTX 470 and it certainly would
have been from the RTX
370 now for those of you after a more
positive take the good news here being
that the RTX 5090 is faster than the 490
allowing it to take 4K gaming to that
next step where it is very possible to
enjoy a truly High refresh rate
experience so if you already had Oodles
of money to blow on a graphics card and
You' missed out on the 4 490 then the 90
will be a very welcomed release but in a
nutshell the RTX 590 is 25% more
expensive than the 4090 while being on
average 27% faster at 4K it has 33% more
vram and consumes around 30% more power
so interpret that how you'd like but for
now we are done with our review so be
sure to let me know what you think about
the RTX 490 TI I mean
Steve the joke's not getting on
B is just laughing in the background um
RTX 590 let me know what you think about
the RTX 590 in the comments section
below I'm very keen to hear your
thoughts of course the people who are
excited to buy it are going to buy it
anyway um I don't think the $2,000 us
price tag or what we've seen here
changes that but maybe it does so if you
were going to buy one and for whatever
reason you're not now yeah be sure to
let me know in the comment section below
we do have a lot more 5090 and other
GeForce 50 series content coming up in
the coming days and weeks so make sure
you subscribe for that give this video a
like if you appreciated our review we
also have the join button and our
patreon account if you want to join our
exclusive Discord server monthly live
streams behind the scenes content Q&A
stuff there a lot of cool things so
check that if you're interested but if
not that is perfectly fine and I would
like to thank you for watching this
review of the RTX 49 TI I'm your host
Steve see you next time
[Music]